[Music]
twas the night before Christmas when all
through the house not a creature was
stirring except for Center who was dying
I'm dying ah our YouTube algorithm
Skellig Santa all of the elfs are dead
all of the reindeers are dead even
Rudolph
nothing can save me Christmas is surely
doomed
there is one cure known to man can hello
grandma sold Christmas cake it's been
known to cure any disease at
Christmastime in order to save Christmas
you must first save Santa Klaus
don't worry Center it's all gonna be
fine it goes on it
[Music]
here we go like [ __ ] let's get it right
here one thing here we go
okay oh boy [ __ ] I can't wrap a sec hey
oh all right yeah
[Music]
first ingredient in grandma's recipe is
flower Rama used to be a flower-mobile
now let's be very careful with the eggs
anything could happen
that second ingredient is eggs goodbye
my log love eggs gentle gentle gentle
God Santa's gonna feel great same just
gonna feel so good and now oh look oh
now just a hint of salt you ready one
two Nick God brainless secret stash it
makes you feel nice and warm grandma you
after having find a dank shake grandma
with a little bit of a drinker
and by a little bit I mean holy [ __ ]
head down I'm not wasting it
No
all right here we go
there ya go
perfect Josh starts it Washington now
this let's give it a good sniff oh yeah
next ingredient
every Christmas was a sad memory because
grandma was alcoholic but we have to
honor recipe Wow all right I love it
[Music]
next thing grandma was also addicted to
plastic cups she loved heroin cocaine
and any pills you could find really
Santa have a little taste
you gotta pour it a lot before everybody
so good once this is sending up and I'm
sure I will be a hundred percent but
until then oh hey by the way Santa what
did you get me for Christmas that's
funny you should ask akka a loot anime
wanna open it together yes
I'm sponsored loot crate that will do
just great okay the first item is ichigo
kurosaki pants oh my god you love pants
so much that he goes away
oh my god it's Ichigo my favorite Naruto
character
there you go Edgar whoa what is this oh
my god I love these
it's our ancient cross all right a
scroll a magical scroll you found it
whoo what is this
it's a manga sort out online that's cool
I want to read this one lootcrate
exclusive so it's like an OVA you
[ __ ] nerve oh [ __ ] yeah okay this is
berserk one of my favorite anime it's a
blade letter opener whoa that's cool
it's his sword this sword is like the
most badass sword in any like fiction
[ __ ] and I've ever read about it's so
cool whoa it's this anime posters oh
yeah
I'll definitely put this on my wall the
final ingredient that we've been looking
for you found it but I'm still dying but
there's a way to save another way to
save Center sign up between November
28th and December 27 to get December's
themed galaxy it's got stuff from Cowboy
Bebop and Sailor Moon go to loot crate
Kansai boots
enter the code pits and save 10% now
hurry I must be fast and what
I did it a smash to go in the oven
Tata Tata
yeah okay here we go
Jesus Christ it must be cooked for seven
minutes in 77 seconds for Santa I will
save you it's done the masterpiece that
was saved Christmas
[ __ ] luckily there's one left let's see
what Santa
[Music]
Oh Edgar you came for me
Oh
I'll thank you I've got Christmas the
same you saved my life
you're safe I didn't save you I saved
Christmas now a guy I believe you owe me
a face massage oh and God gentle gentle
gentle oh yeah
Oh
[Music]
[Music]